welcome to the show we're trying
something a little bit different today
I'm going to be joined today for the
hour by Dave Rubin host of the political
talk show the Rubin report on YouTube
our sort of daily political wrap-up and
stories will be on today's bonus show so
extra incentive to sign up for that
bonus show so Dave it's been I think it
may be about a year or more since we
last had you on and why when I announced
we were going to be having you on
we received close to 500 different
questions and and concerns and maybe
about 50 insults which is about the
right ratio that I find for you and
we're going to dig into a bunch of this
stuff but to sort of set this up I got a
tweet from someone the other day
unrelated to this interview who said I
like a diverse media diet
I watched the David Pakman show on the
left and I watched the Reuben report on
the right which was sort of surprising
to me it what's your assessment now of
where your politics are do you consider
yourself to be on the right so to speak
yeah well you've given me a lot there to
start so I'll do the best I can here
back man yeah first off the 500
questions to only 50 haters or insults
that that's an extremely for the
Internet in 2017 that's a phenomenally
good ratio so I want to be clear about
that first as far as that now I'll dress
it in a broad sense first and then I'll
get to your exact question in the broad
sense the person that commented on that
that's a beautiful thing and that's
exactly what we need more of regardless
of left-right or anything else or what
you think about my politics or your
politics we need more people that are
willing to listen to people from across
the spectrum and in in ways that you
wouldn't have listened to people years
ago meaning do it through podcasts or
YouTube or however else you do it now
and all those things what we need more
than ever in this country I believe is a
multitude of voices who are trying to
get across ideas so that we can have the
battle of ideas so we can figure out
what the best way to move forward as to
the specific question of okay I listen
to pac-man I left proven on right I mean
I have said consistently we relaunched
this show you
I was at the Young Turks for a while as
you were an affiliate with them as well
at the time we relaunched the show where
it became an interview show basically
two years ago is September 9th 2015 so
I'm sure about a month and that's when I
had Sam Harrison on that first episode
and we did a one-on-one interview and
the second I was done with that
interview I thought wow this is what I
want to do you know before that I was
doing sort of a news panel thing and I'd
have three guests usually comedians a
little more like hot topics on the view
or something but I did that show with
Sam and I thought wow we did into
something important and relevant and
real and honest and I and I loved
interviewing people and I had done it
before a little bit I had a show on
Sirius XM and some other stuff but
that's really where I shifted that's
where I started talking about these
ideas of liberalism and the phrase
classical liberalism which I'm proud to
say is now out there in the in the ether
yeah and you hear this being spoken
about more I mean nobody was talking
about that and I still have all sorts of
problems with people usually on the
right by the way who still associate
everything else a Liberals this liberals
this when they really mean they either
mean progressives or they mean people of
the left which sort of gets to the heart
of your question so first off I don't
think the left the right thing really
has much bearing anymore I've said this
many times but I think the Trump elect
you know the election and then the Trump
presidency has tossed the chessboard up
I had Andrew Clavin on here a couple
weeks ago he said it rammed the truck
through everything whatever metaphor you
want to use for it it has created a
situation where everybody is really a
ting whatever it is that they believe
and why they believe it so when you just
say the typical ideas of the left or of
the right to me it's really more about
libertarian versus authoritarian I don't
mean libertarian in the political party
I mean a sense of individual liberty
versus sort of state authority
technically look technically if we were
to get all the definitions in the
old-school way of looking at them
classical liberalism which is pretty
close to lib to libertarianism
practically is thought of as on the
right side of the spectrum so I don't
again I think these things are kind of
archaic ways of talking about things but
you know we all get caught in labels I
say it all the time you know I have to
use labels at some level to get ideas
across and then at the same time as
labels change they become less useful
which by the way it's one of the reasons
that I don't say regressive left as much
as I used to because I think we made a
point with it and people started
understanding what we were talking about
because for a long time people were sort
of thinking a lot of the things that
that you and I have discussed they were
thinking these things they needed a
label to sort of grasp what we were
talking about now I think people
understand it so I've shipped it away
now some people use it more that so be
it but anyway if you want to get down to
the technical side of it I would say
that that true liberalism classical
liberalism which is about the individual
and live-and-let-live and and logic and
reason I would say that that's firmly
truly in the center because what you're
really trying to do is is bring in the
fringes because you realize that most of
us are in somewhere in the center yeah I
mean I see but I think that also there's
a lot there I mean to sort of get to
whether your politics have changed
because that's one of the big questions
is so aside from where however you label
your place on the spectrum there are
many who believe your politics have
decidedly changed when you used to be
arguably sort of under the progressive
umbrella but you differed with some of
your colleagues on issues of free speech
and censorship and the
israeli-palestinian conflict - really
now under the label of classical
liberalism supporting more genuinely
right-wing ideas before we dig into any
specific policy do you believe that your
views have actually changed or are you
labeling your views in a different way
no my views have been change I've said
this a couple of times if anything I
would say on some economic stuff I've
shifted a little bit more libertarian so
I'm taxes for example or on some
regulation stuff which I'm happy to
discuss if you want but in terms of
everything else in terms of gay marriage
I'm married to a dude he's in the other
room
that's pretty for gay marriage I'm for
legalizing marijuana I'm for euthanasia
for reforming the prison system I'm
pro-choice I'm basically for
single-payer health care these are all
things that are thought of as either
or last or liberal or whatever so yeah
I've shifted a little bit on some of the
economic stuff because by the way for
the last two years I've sat across some
brilliant thinkers and public
intellectuals and professors mostly
people that have argued in front of the
Supreme Court I mean experts in their
field who have shifted some of my views
a little bit right in terms of economics
well in terms of everything else I
believe those same things by the way I
will say this that when I was on The
Young Turks I always considered myself
liberal I don't think you'll ever find a
moment where I flat out said I was a
progressive I was around a lot of
progressives and at the time I thought a
lot of what they said made sense but
then as I sort of had my awakening you
know one of the things that I think a
lot of your audience will be familiar
with this and maybe you are to a degree
as well is that when you start seeing
the corrosive effect of a lot of this
stuff that's happening on the Left right
now it starts under it undermines almost
all of the rest of it at once but and
once you see it you can't stop it's like
a wave and then you go wait a minute
this one little thing I think a little
differently on this and and suddenly you
see why it affects so many other issues
yes I mean let's pot let's pause on that
part because I do want to dig in more
into detail on that in a subsequent part
of the interview but to get to the
politics of it the policies you describe
a lot of them they they're sort of at
odds with classical liberalism I mean
want to give you one example and I'm
wondering maybe if the classical
liberalism term is being used a little
too loosely right now by some and we're
doing a long form deep dive into
classical liberalism that will be out in
a couple of weeks I mean one example
would be a sort of foundational
classical liberalism tenet is the
government should be involved not at all
in anything that the free market can
provide now it's not can provide
efficiently or can provide pretty well
but can provide so according to
classical liberalism health care is
something that should be 100 percent in
the free market and that means no
pre-existing conditions or it costs 10
times as much if you have pre-existing
conditions
Asians or whatever it is that for-profit
corporations want to do the view you
stated yourself having on single-payer
health care it could not be more opposed
to classical liberalism so is it
possible it's maybe not the right label
for you no it's not possible it's not
the right label because I know all the
types of classical liberalism quite well
and I and I assure you it's not look
I've had many people on I would
recommend your your audience check out
some of my interviews with Steve Davies
with Randy Barnett with Deidre McCloskey
these are these are professors at what
very well-known schools who've explained
a lot of this stuff brandon davies from
cleansing a bunch of other people sorry
Brandon Turner basically I think for
this look we can we can whittle down
every definition to every this is
exactly how you have to think if you're
this or that I mean we could we could
sit here and go well you know you're
only a Democrat if you exactly believe
this or exactly believe that nobody
Democrat I think that's it to be clear
Democrat is a political party
affiliation and I think that's very
different than an ideology like
classical liberalism which has some
pretty well-defined characteristics sure
so for most of the guests that I've had
on here who identifies as classical
liberals I would venture to say almost
everybody actually the easiest way I can
explain it is that if you are a pure
libertarian and and this is hard to pin
down because libertarians are sort of
all over the place you have the wing of
libertarians that don't want driver's
licenses and then you have libertarians
think of a little more realistic and
then and then by the way you have an
Capps who want absolutely no government
and all that stuff
classical liberals generally I think
believe that the principles of the
individual and of Liberty and your right
to do things for yourself and
free-market principles by the way are
the best way to go about doing things
but there's a realism there related to
the state which is that it exists it has
to provide certain things especially in
a country like America where we have 300
or 350 million people whatever it is and
that there has to be some balance so
I've seen many times and this would be
the the view that I look at a classical
liberal position generally it sort of it
sort of takes the libertarian
principal and then add some element of
realistic government involvement so you
know we can whittle down to those words
being absolute necessity or whatever it
is but I think the general accepted term
is that there's some government
involvement but you want to always err
on the side of individual freedom which
I absolutely do on the issue of the
single-payer health care though because
I think this is a good lens specifically
because of your views on this do you
agree that single-payer would not be the
libertarian perspective with a slight
tweak to make it the classically liberal
perspective it is diametrically opposed
to what a classical liberal would want
yeah you know it's funny I I get invited
to a lot of college things and I'm
always invited by the way--by
by conservatives or libertarians usually
or people of the right which is funny to
me because you'd think it shows that
they're certainly willing to talk to
people who are pro-choice and Pro
and I get no invites from anyone left so
I was doing a speech for the students
for Liberty in DC a couple maybe two
months ago and I'm talking about all
these things that I'm for and I said
something about the Hinkel single-payer
healthcare and they booed me but then
everyone started laughing after because
it was very obvious that the whole
purpose of me brink coming there was
that we don't have to agree on
everything and then we all had a good
laugh about it I thought what a great
moment that is that we can all go you
know what we still want to live in the
same country anyway as far as
single-payer health care this isn't I
haven't done a tremendous amount on
health care on the show and I should do
more actually why is that
or maybe we'll save that for later
because I noticed that that you don't
talk about that and it's potentially
affecting you know tens of millions of
people tomorrow you know what I mean I
was surprised that you weren't talking
as much about it
um I think it's sort of about ancillary
bounced in and out of the specific you
know I what I try to do on the show is I
like talking about the principles and
the ideas mostly and I try not to get
caught in the sort of day to day the
news part of it and especially because
of the way people consume news now it's
like everything changes so quickly in
the 24-hour news cycle changes so
quickly that I don't want to always be
doing the catch up on that but but what
that's fine I would say that to me the
best idea for healthcare as I see it
would be that basically you would have
the the private companies would be in
control because they have to decide what
they have to make money they have to
have a functioning business I do believe
that's a realistic thing at the same
time there is a piece of do you want
people to be able to get health
insurance that have pre-existing
conditions absolutely do you want to do
things that aren't always about the
bottom line that this is where a
libertarian might say okay well it's
tough for that person and they have to
go to their local church or their
whatever their community and help them
now I believe the state does have some
responsibilities there I think this is a
classical liberal position so so I would
say the best the most realistic way that
I think you could do this basically
would be that you would have private
companies that would sort of all be
facilitated and exchanged with some
facilitating by the government it isn't
that Obamacare like isn't that Obamacare
basically said we're still keeping
health insurance as a for-profit
endeavor but in order to participate you
have to abide by certain restrictions
and we will also sort of regulate some
portion of these plans through an
exchange like I'm hearing exactly what
the Affordable Care Act is yeah well
first off you can go back to my tweets
and many videos that I did I was not
against Obamacare yeah no and I don't
read as a criticism and it's just
sounding like what the Affordable Care
Act well I wasn't I wasn't against
Obamacare I was frustrated with a lot of
how they did it you know I'm not someone
that believes that the ends justify the
means and if you remember when Obama was
running he was constantly talking about
how transparent we're going to be and
we're going to air this stuff on c-span
and everyone although and we know whose
all backdoor deals and congressmen that
were suddenly retiring out of nowhere
after they sign things and all kinds of
shady stuff but that's just government
nonsense which is another reason why for
small government as a general rule I
think that there is some overreach by
the government on I have a some issue
with the government forcing people to
buy something there's something there
but I could I can basically get over
that look I can tell you this I have a
very good friend who
for the last ten ten or fifteen years
has been a very successful doctor I
don't want to say what state he's in but
a very successful doctor Obamacare came
in and his practice in many ways has
been wrecked because he stuck with all
these regulations at doing more
paperwork than seeing people and all
this other stuff now I know that's just
an antic total thing but you do hear a
lot of these stories so the basic
premise though of what you're saying
having some exchange that the government
says you have to sort of hit these
certain marks I just don't know that
it's exactly been rolled out properly I
think there's a lot of evidence that it
hasn't but again I mean look at the day
Obamacare was passed I tweeted something
that got something like 50 was 50
thousand retweets which at the time I
think was one of the top 10 most
retweeted things ever so but so Dave I'm
trying to I just want to just so we can
drill down so you're you're agreeing
that what you described as your ideal
scenario sounds like Obamacare but your
problem with Obamacare isn't how it was
written but rather that the
implementation wasn't exactly as it was
designed um well no there are first of
all for stuff I'm not a health care
expert I mean I know everyone wants to
pretend they're experts and everything I
don't it seems to me that there are
probably unnecessary regulations or
expectations out of some of the
insurance companies and and the doctors
frankly I'm working I'm less concerned
about a giant corporation that's an
insurance company that we know companies
make tons and tons of money I'm much
more concerned about the ability for the
doctor and the patient to have the best
relationship possible the doctor to make
the right choices which I've heard a lot
of things from from several doctors that
there are reasons sometimes that they
can't even make the best choices that
they think to do or sometimes they'll do
a procedure before they think it's
necessary all sorts of other stuff but
the basic premise of what Obamacare is
of the government facilitating the
private exchanges I don't have a don't
have a problem with it but like most
things private or public but especially
public it could probably be done a
little better fair enough yeah and as
far as you know I think that one of the
big issues is if we had single-payer and
we had also outcome based compensation
rather than you get paid for each thing
that you do which is sort of one of the
key aspects of the system we have you
would eliminate a lot of what we're
seeing doctors doing but let's put a
pause on the healthcare conversation and
in fact we'll take a quick break and
then Dave we will resume with you and we
just have so much else to talk about
we're speaking with Dave Rubin host of
the Rubin report and we'll be back after
this